two starts ago he was electric most
strikeouts in his career last start
you're like well wait what happened
there yeah last start just didn't have
any control but
start watching the sinker tonight there
is jesse winker one pitch going the
other way and a good start for the reds
at winker not wasting any time
he's had a lot of success off a hauser
as well
mainly because hauser is a sinker ball
pitcher and winker he's got four home
runs this year on sinker balls
mike mustakas on the injured list two so
it's
figuring out what six right now
meanwhile stevenson draws a walk
[Applause]
red's with two runners on that's
important they're the best in the majors
hitting with runners in scoring position
and this one hit high in the air deep
right field you can forget it it's gone
let us start for the reds and a
three-run bomb for tyler naked this ball
just left out over the plate and your
left-handed hitters because of their
swing path typically have success
against sinker ball pitchers and you can
see that pitch right-handed single ball
pitchers you can see that pitch just
leak out over the plate and again the
swing path for left-handers is more of
an uppercut swing
well that's the thing he comes over to
cincinnati and they are
you know very analytic driven
vogelback puts it in play tough play
hoffman on the run back foot throw way
off the mark and down the line it goes
vogelback not going to go anywhere
though jose there
[Applause]
and he missed it high but in tights
and the first walk by hoffman giving the
brewers some life here in the second
inning
what does he do here on a 3-2
[Music]
lost control it's in the dirt the bases
are loaded
so given a three-nothing lead he struck
out noravaya to start the inning and
then a walk
excuse me a single and two walks and
each of those batters he had one in two
as you pointed out
and so the bases are loaded for luis
urias which is kind of a fascinating
case because
the brewers will get more into this in a
little bit they go out and trade for
willy adams from the race today so arias
this is essentially his last day of
starting shortstop for the brewers
payoff
fastball
josh miss lowe barnhart wanted that one
somehow uria's
laid off and he walks in a run
three consecutive walks and the brewers
are on the board
it's a heck of a pitch but it is low
ureas does a nice job of staying out but
you know hoffman obviously he wants that
pitch
barnhart
does a good job of trying to sell it
brings that up
jesse winker has
has hit hauser well
in his time against him now six for 11
with three home runs against hauser he's
singled in the first
winker drives one deep right center it's
gone
number nine on the year for jesse winker
in his 4-1 cincinnati that one hit 431
feet winker absolutely destroyed it
and it was not an over swing by winker
he just
got his hands to the baseball the pitch
was down and in and it was a live drive
out of here to right center field really
more towards center than right center
and that will bring up the former mvp in
christian yelich
who's over two tonight over nine since
coming off the injured list is hoffman
now
in a season high for pitches throwing at
92
3-2 one more time high heat and he got
him
as you were saying eric carros
pretty impressive from jeff hoffman 4-1
reds
[Music]
and again it's just i'm not sure that
hauser has
here we go hauser has anything to get
him out the answer is he doesn't
another home run for winker another hit
against hauser and his tenth of the year
is 5-1 cincinnati
he just destroys sinkers
and hauser that's that's his pitch and
what do we got here
it's the same it's the same pitch
i mean you think about it so winker is
three for three tonight
so he's eight for 13 with five home runs
against hauser in his career
stunning that that matchup was allowed
to happen
so now it's tucker barnhart still only
one away
barnhart gets into one carrying to right
on the track is bradley jr he will haul
it in castillanos will walk on home
not a grand slam but a sacrifice fly
will do and the reds up their lead to
six to one
[Applause]
marias turns on one down the line and it
is deep and it's one hopped off the wall
it's a fair ball jackie bradley jr going
into third he'll stop there and aureus
has a double
three is a pinch hitter with a chance to
get the brewers back in this game
1-0 and he golfed it and popped it up
winker puts it away and jackie bradley
jr is going to come on in and he will
score and they're fine with that so the
brewers add one sec fly by mckinney make
it six to two
kane
hits it hard to left winker on his horse
it's over his head off the wall runners
had to hang on for a second here comes
zaria's he'll come in and score juan
stops at third it's an rbi double and a
bullet from lorenzo kane and the brewers
within three
winker unable to do anything in this
situation just because it's hit so hard
right over his head
maria's waited for a while i think wong
would have scored easily but arias
really waited
for a long time to go
two off speed pitches
another one yellows to the left side
wong's gonna come home and score
and that'll get another run hole
so yell it's grounds out but it's a six
to four ball game as kane holds it
second
[Music]
fastball lined it's a basic
suarez gonna come around third he's
being waved in here comes the throw it's
up the line he will score
a two out rbi base hit from kyle farmer
and the reds get back up to a three-run
lead
left side it gets through that's a base
hit barnhart coming around third here
comes the throw it's not in time and
india delivers a two out base hit and
the reds and on again
on a good night if you're a reds fan it
could be another jessie waker
yeah it is
the third of the night for jesse winker
they want the current call
i mean it's just a little cutter up in
the zone
you know not much velocity at all and
winker just absolutely destroys it
showing his love for cincy
[Applause]
got him
and that's the ball game brad brock
comes in his first appearance has a red
it helps
shut it down on a rousing 9-4 win by
cincinnati on a three-home run night
for that man jesse winker